Think you know a lot about music?
Here's 23 random music facts that'll blow your mind.
Aerosmith's "I Don't Wanna Miss a Thing" was originally written
for Celine Dion.
Madonna's "Like a Virgin"
is actually about a guy getting over a breakup.
Sorry, Mr. Brown,
"Summer of '69" is about the sexual position.
Sarah McLachlan's "Angel"
is about heroin addiction.
Semisonic's "Closing Time"
is not about last call,
but rather the birth the lead singer's daughter.
The Goo Goo Dolls' "Slide"
is about abortion.
"A Boy Named Sue" was not written by Johnny Cash,
but rather Shel Silverstein.
Shel wrote, "A Boy Named Sue," among other things.
"Gettin' Jiggy Wit It"
was written by Nas.
"Nothing Compares to You" and "Manic Monday"
were both written by Prince.
Cee Lo's "Forget You"
was written by Bruno Mars
And Justin Timberlake's "Rock Your Body" was written by Pharrell
for Michael Jackson's final album.
Alanis Morissette's "You Oughta Know"
is supposedly about Full House's Dave Coulier.
Gwen Stefani's "Hollaback Girl" is a response to Courtney Love's slam of Gwen
in Seventeen magazine.
Okay, now pay attention.
Britney's "Toxic" was originally written for Kylie Minogue.
and "I'm a Slave 4 U" was originally written for Janet Jackson.
TLC passed on "Baby One More Time,"
while Britney herself passed on Lady Gaga's "Telephone"
and Rihanna's "Umbrella."
Meanwhile Rihanna passed on Miley's "We Can't Stop,
but recorded "Disturbia" instead of Chris Brown.
Did you get all that?
P!nk and Hilary Duff both turned down Kelly Clarkson's
"Since U Been Gone."
Shania Twain and Faith Hill both turndown Beyonce's "Irreplaceable."
Michael Jackson's "Bad" was originally supposed to be a duet with Prince.
And finally, "Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds" is not about LSD.
This is the truth: my son came home with a drawing
and showed me this strange-looking woman flying around.
I said, "What is it?" He said "It's Lucy in the Sky with Diamonds."
And I thought, "That's beautiful."
I immediately wrote a song about it.
Check the description for sources
and let us know your favorite music fact.